As you remember, Objective-C is pretty
blase about its handling of nil values.
Like Desmir mentioned, by default any
object can be nil in Objective-C.
>From Swift's perspective, the danger of
nil values lurks around every corner.
If your Swift code is
consuming Objective-C code,
you need to be constantly checking for
nil values.
Unexpected nil values that are handled
incorrectly can crash your app.
To see how an unexpected null value
might get passed to your Swift code,
let's take a look at how Objective-C
gets translated into Swift by default.
Let's say we have an Objective-C
class that represents a user.
Our user class has properties
representing a user's name, email, and
avatar.
And down here we have an initializer
that takes two strings as parameters but
doesn't take an avatar.
Not every user has an avatar.
If we click on this icon
in the top left corner,
down at the bottom of the menu we see
this option for Generated interface.
Clicking that option gives us the
interface that's generated for Swift.
So, okay,
we've got some Swift code now and
we see name, avatar, and
email along with the init method.
But we also see a lot
of exclamation points.
By default, Swift treats every
variable coming from Objective-C
as an implicitly unwrapped optional.
As we know, implicitly unwrapped
optionals are dangerous.
We don't want to be accidentally
unwrapping null values.